yes in my experience the phrase better
late than never is what lazy people say
to justify the fact that they were late
on something so the peanuts came out
last weekend now I'm reviewing it better
late than never the peanuts movie so the
peanuts movie is the return of Charles
Schulz classic characters to peanuts you
got everyone you got Charlie Brown you
got peppermint patty Linus Lucy Snoopy
that dude that dances like this they're
all here and once again Charlie Brown is
here to do his best in a world that
doesn't really except his best I was
feel bad for Charlie Brown when I see
these movies this movie's no exception
in that they accurately represented the
peanuts in this movie because Charlie
Brown is just a little outcast and
you're rooting for him you feel so bad
for him the funny thing and fascinating
thing about the peanuts is the fact that
so many people relate to the peanuts in
that they relate to Charlie Brown which
means if a lot of people relate to
Charlie Brown that means a lot of people
just try their best and fail at it and
there's no shame in that whatsoever now
for the first half an hour in this movie
I was like what's this movie about other
than the fact that nostalgia Cleary
living another peanuts adventure but
look what's it about and how they
execute is there's an overall point to
it the point is there's this new girl in
school Charlie Brown has a crush on her
so he's trying to impress her so it's
ultimately I believe it's three
different scenarios in this movie that
are ultimately peanuts episodes like for
a half an hour he does this to try to
impress her and peanut shenanigans ensue
and then the next half hour
peanut shenanigans ensue in the next
half hour another thing in penis
shenanigans ensue three different parts
three different shenanigans three
different points but it's all like
aiming towards the same thing for
Charlie Brown so it's basically three
peanuts episodes in one in about 45
minutes in this movie I was like okay
that's how they're all right and then it
clicked for me and the fact is I think
people are gonna have a good time with
this movie who's gonna have a good time
with this movie that is the question
there are lessons in the peanuts movie
kids can learn from this is not just
nonsense thrown on the screen for the
sake of just colors I like that it's a
remarkably rare thing this day and age
but I think more than that the adults
that grew up on the peanuts adventures
when they were kids they're going to
love this movie because there's a lot of
nostalgia in this movie it is a new
adventure for Charlie Brown and company
it's clearly of peanuts movie they even
like made the frame rate for the
characters bump down it's not 24 frames
a second it's lit looks like 15 to 20 it
makes it look like the peanuts movies of
all of it was really impressed with that
I like stylistic choices like that this
movie
spoon-feed nostalgia to the point where
you do back up you're like you're just
kind of throwing nostalgic situational
circumstance and lines from the previous
peanuts adventures into this one for the
sake of that nostalgia bomb is that lazy
and I had to scratch my head from him
and I'm like why do some movies get
berated for that other movies get a pass
I go looking in the eye and be like yeah
the peanuts did that and it worked out
well for it however Terminator Genisys
ultimately did the same thing they took
the lines of old put it in the new movie
and it's like well that's lazy here
it is if you're going to do that make
sure your movie is good also if you have
a crappy movie with a bunch of nostalgic
lines of old in it it looks like you're
using the nostalgia to keep the movie
afloat but if you have a good movie that
happens to have nostalgic lines in
situations in it it looks like it's just
using it as a topping not using the
nostalgia as the sole means of survival
I just wish Hollywood would learn that
at a point
I mean undeniably by the end of this
movie you get the feels it's a heartfelt
movie it's a heartwarming movie by the
end you just you so adore Charlie Brown
and you love Snoopy because Snoopy is
really the only one who gives Lucy any
grief and one important thing I learned
from this movie is that Charlie Brown's
world would be much better if Lucy ended
up on a milk carton seriously she is an
I mean I always knew she was but
seeing it through adult eyes you see
you're like oh my god come on Lucy that
is unacceptable you need to be smacked
she's unlikable I just don't like her as
a person or a character she's why I'm
the one Family Guy episode when Peter
Griffin beat the piss out of her I
laughed I felt good because that was a
pretty good vindication for Charlie
Brown guys in the end the peanuts movie
is exactly what you want the peanuts
movie to be if you want to see a new
peanuts movie because you grew up on the
peanuts they do all the characters great
justice the characters are exactly how
you remember the characters being
because enjoyment for kids there's
enjoyment for adults and there's
relevance and I will certainly say the
peanuts movie is worth buying on blu-ray
okay so the peanuts movie have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you